and Esther is a I mean I'm gonna say
this I like to give people props where
they deserve it you I am gonna be honest
with you there is been no one like you
in the stand-up comedy world I don't
know if that's a good thing but but
there has been no one like you in the 20
years that I've been doing stand-up you
know what even from an outsider's
perspective you have a very very
specific and particular voice and look
and overall the image compared to anyone
else and I think that's you know such a
great advantage for you just because
you're odd you're in a way that like
Jeffrey Dahmer
you're not Jeffrey you're more like no
you're like you know you know like back
in the day when they starting the circus
never ages but I also want to say that
you're young and I also I love you is
that where you're very neurotic like I
am you get diarrhea all the time no I
don't - does oh really yeah cuz he told
me once your boyfriend he told me once
he takes up what's up imodium a-d before
meals just in case what makes me in the
cave imagine a commode every meal and
just in case you're gonna get diarrhea
it's living life in a prison no he's
being safe it's like putting a cork in
it so that it never exactly wear condoms
but like you should address what is the
problem it's probably IBS yeah if it
just goes through them each time
speaking of what is the problem
[Music]
maybe I should ester our relationship is
very strange because kalila is a nurse
it's strictly a nurse patient
relationship if you go through the whole
of the history of our text messages it's
just a bunch of pictures of Esther's
rashes the inside of her mouth yeah like
her tonsils yeah her CT scan I stopped
watching photos I mean is Esther I got I
got one okay I don't know how I want to
deal with this so text me from New
Zealand I think I'm dying
what do I love about what what no rashes
do you get I get all sorts of rashes I
well when I was in New Zealand I had a
swollen lymph node
kalila helped me so much like I I don't
even know where to start but there's so
many like she's just so good in the very
real life like knowing her as me in my
life significantly better you're a touch
hypochondriasis
when I'm texting you like I'm like I
know this is crazy yeah hopefully I say
that and when I when I was switching
over phones and I was like hey like
sorry I didn't reply back your phone my
phone's broken
she was like okay make sure you have a
phone soon a new phone soon like it was
a legit concern for her just in case
like a new rash
you know sprouts up
[Music]